prince harry compare sa femme meghan
markle à sa mère lady di bref au surplus
on avait parlé semaine dernière il s'en
prend médias en faisant un rapprochement
tu t'énerves est d'ailleurs en disant
que ce n'était pas les médias et les
paparazzi qui avait tué les dix 10 ans
tout ce que vit son couple aujourd'hui
est ce qu a vécu sa propre mère mais
malgré tout il existe hors se répète ça
on en a parlé mais il prend la défense
de défense de meghan markle voilà où il
dit en tant que couple nous croient en
la liberté des médias malheureusement
mon épouse est l'une des plus récentes
victimes d'un tabloïd britannique qui
fait campagne contre des personnes sans
penser aux conséquences propagande un
capa implacable pardon a un coût humain
en particulier lorsqu'elle est
intentionnellement fossé de mauvaise foi
nous voilà on vous a posé une question
de prince harry et ils manipulés par
meghan markle c'est une question qu'on
s'est posée parce qu'aujourd'hui voilà
aujourd'hui on donc alors oui non oui
non oui non oui non oui non oui
sébastien pourquoi est ce qu'il y est il
est manipulé par sa femme eh bien
écoutez vous avez qu à regarder le harry
d'avant mégane et le aride maintenant il
ya un changement tellement évident sais
pas j'étais bien à voir qui qu'elle a
une influence donc maintenant est ce
qu'on peut appeler ça de la manipulation
mais elle a une influence il influence
qui est pas toujours bonne normalement
un membre de la famille royale ne va pas
critiquer la presse en plus le papa le
parallèle avec diana diana a été une
femme qui a énormément joué avec la
presse donc voilà elle est d'une grande
manipulatrice de la presse elle s'est
servie de la presse donc on voit aussi
que tout l'entourage de harry disparaît
petit à petit ça soit son frère avec qui
les fâche et sans doute d'autres membres
de la famille et tous les employés les
plus proches qui partent les uns
derrière les autres
donc là aussi on peut pas imaginer qu'il
se passe quelque chose et que elle a une
influence énorme
non mais j'ai juste rectifier la reine
la reine victoria avait en son temps à
attaquer la presse c'est pas le premier
en fait la presse anglaise considère
qu'une famille dont le dans le train de
vie et payés par le contribuable
on doit forcément tout prendre et eux
ils disent je suis désolé nous ne sommes
pas un supermarché dans lequel on peut
venir se servir des travail et non mais
attends
il a vraiment raison il ya un moment où
pris en photo et souris soit ils vont en
fait ils vont travailler ailleurs
mais il travaille ni travail illégal des
vouent leur vie entière à l'essai
recueilli autant des prisonniers pour
étendre entre temps en temps des princes
c'est oui mais attention ils sont payés
le vous donnez pas pour pas pour l'heure
à rien à brûler toute leur vie c'est
toute leur vie que ça va durer leur
travail sept jours sur sept sans aide
on peut toujours dire on peut toujours
dire on n'y va pas avec mais je ne suis
pas allé avec le dos il a changé en quoi
il a changé c'est le même là où je
rejoins sébastien il est quand tu es né
dans une famille royale que des à petit
à deux ans te dit tu seras roy tire à te
faire chier tirer dans les ehpad dire
bonjour et les machins t'as pas le choix
ta vie est écrite la l'a voulu et les
venues des états unis et son hamburger
pour chercher un anglais et la chine
mais en quoi elle l'a voulu mais attend
d elle elle envoie une lettre à 100 tout
est née d'une histoire elle envoie une
lettre à son père pour s'expliquer
évidemment le père à fils et la lettre à
la presse et le gardien qu'il allait
débarquer attendu mais pleins de foi
mais non il à ce garçon a perdu son pari
en obtenant des petits arabes annoncé
par guillaume sol ont pu voir toutes les
missions on dit tout myriam à partir du
moment où son père n'est pas invité à
son mariage c'est obligé que nous presse
people ou autre on va se poser des
questions il combat certes on va savoir
à ça parce que vous avez le goût du sang
on n'a pas du tout
gong mathieu et enfin pour votre cour il
va dire lorsqu'on est jamais oui les
manipuler mais il a on vit ça il a envie
et savez vous avez un scoop
en fait ben guillaume nous avoue à 20
ans il s'est mis à fumer pour faire un
peu punk devant une fille parce qu'il
faisait trop mou d'allissa et bah lui
c'est pareil il en avait marre d'être
dans une famille tellement clean c'est
ouvert mars à ce bal with you
il en avait marre il a voulu il est
conscient du truc il a voulu ça mais oui
très bien nous attend il ya un blanche
jeu quand même vérifier
vous vivez à temps ça peut arriver
suivez mon doigt non ça va parce que
vous avez vous fait peur il ya des
blancs comme ça va olala sondage des
amis de courtage sondages le prince
harry et ils manipulés par meghan markle
r61 merci la voilà que la france qui est
mal informé parce qu'on peut penser à
l'agneau mais la france qui est bien
informé grâce à nous maintenant pour
seront comme mathieu et comme sébastien